Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about we
are just asking questions.
We are just asking questions.
I'm going to play you a clip from CNN of James
Colmer being interviewed by Kaitlan Collins
and confronted about a conspiracy theory he
floated about the Chinese balloon.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 6: One thing you said as we were learning
about this balloon and tracking it, you asked
on Fox News, is it bioweapons in that balloon?
Did that balloon take off from Wuhan?
We don't know anything about it.
But you don't have any evidence that this.
No.
Speaker 7: I asked the question.
I mean, what is in the balloon?
This is something that we believe the White
House should have advised us.
So they should have had a briefing to tell
us what this was.
I think back home in Kentucky, this is all
anybody talks about was this flu.
Everyone was concerned.
Speaker 1: In Kentucky, it was all balloon
24 seven.
Speaker 7: No one trusts China.
They know China is an adversary.
My concern was the military had no idea anything
about the balloon.
What was in the balloon?
Was it a spy balloon?
Was it a weather balloon like China said?
You know, what exactly did the did the US
military know about this?
What did our intelligence know about this?
Did they know it was even in airspace before
it got in the Alaska airspace?
So, you know, it's just a lot of questions.
And that's just one of the questions.
Just for all we know, it could have bioweapons.
They could be testing.
No, no, I didn't ask the question, but.
Speaker 1: He's just asking questions, sort
of like I could say.
Is James Colmer, a pedophile bank robber who
secretly spends his time producing child porn?
Why hasn't anyone investigated it?
Why won't anyone investigate it?
Well, David, because there's no evidence of
that.
I'm just asking questions, as a phrase has
become a really common defense for people
who promote conspiracy theories.
But it's actually a dangerous weaponization
of free speech, because the idea behind I'm
just asking questions is I'm seeking information.
I'm not promoting anything false by asking
a question.
How could I?
It's just a question.
I'm asking a question because I seek information.
But that's of course, not the case when it
comes to a lot of these conspiracy theories.
The people who are just asking questions are
asking questions as a way to promote false,
baseless, sometimes harmful ideas without
having to take the responsibility for the
consequences of floating those ideas.
Someone might say, I'm just asking questions.
Have you ever considered that the moon landing
was faked?
Why haven't you considered it?
Whatever.
And when you look at the intent of that, it
implies there is reason to support the conspiracy
theory when in fact there's overwhelming evidence
to show actually the moon landing was real.
And the problem with this type of rhetoric
is that it lets the false information spread
without being challenged, because at the end
of the day, what's wrong with asking a question?
And it also creates a false equivalency between
here are the established facts and here are
just these are questions and they're just
as valid.
Well, actually there are questions with the
intent to promote a conspiracy theory.
And when someone says I'm just asking questions,
we can evaluate their intention.
Why is it that they are asking this question
and not a different one?
Why is Colmer asking murmur?
He doesn't have evidence for any of this stuff.
Why is he asking Were there what?
What did he say?
Were there bioweapons versus were there Tootsie
Rolls?
Right.
Both would just be questions.
No evidence for either.
Why is he asking one but not the other?
Well, you have to go and look at his intent.
And the intent, of course, is to show exactly
this type of concern about the Biden administration.